germany has made another pledge to
support ukraine with heavy weaponry
announcing today the supply of seven
self-propelled armoured howitzers now
the artillery system which resembles a
tank has a reported range of up to 40
kilometers the german military will also
offer training to ukrainian troops
berlin has been under pressure to do
more to help ukraine defend itself
against the russian invasion last month
the government agreed to export
german-made anti-aircraft tanks
and for more on this i'm joined now by
dw's chief political correspondent
melinda crane melinda welcome germany is
saying it will deliver more heavy
weapons to ukraine what more can you
tell us about that
that's right this announcement was made
this morning by defense minister
lambrecht who is currently visiting
german soldiers deployed in slovakia
where they're helping to reinforce
nato's eastern flank and these seven
howitzers are exactly the kind of heavy
weapons that ukraine has been asking
germany to provide minister lambert said
that germany will also offer training
that has been a source of uncertainty in
the past and one of the reasons that
germany has been hesitant about
delivering heavy weapons because of
concern about how training could be
interpreted by russia whether that could
be seen essentially as making germany a
kind of party to the conflict the german
government has as you said repeatedly
been accused by the leadership in kiev
of not doing enough to help defend it
against the russian invasion and until
just 10 days ago berlin had been quite
reluctant to provide heavy weapons but
chancellor schultz does appear to have
changed course under pressure from
allies and even from his own coalition
partners and has also pledged to export
german-made gaypod armored anti-aircraft
vehicles to ukraine so definitely we are
seeing movement now on the part of
berlin
if we can talk about relations between
berlin and kiev they have been tense
recently after excuse me germany's
president frank walter steinmeier was
told that he was not welcome in ukraine
but according to
chancellor olaf schultz it does seem
that the diploma diplomatic hatchet has
now been buried let's just take a listen
in
the german president and the ukrainian
president spoke very carefully to each
other
that's a good thing
i spoke in detail to the german
president about it beforehand and
afterwards
and the result of the conversation
is that the foreign minister will soon
be in ukraine
so it seems the diplomatic spat has been
smoothed out yet
still isn't going to ukraine why is that
well schultz has in fact in the past
made no secret of his irritation over
the fact that the german president
essentially was disinvited
from visiting ukraine there had been a
very short-term
planned visit when he would have gone
with his polish counterpart and ukraine
rather abruptly said that the german
president would not be welcome and uh
chancellor schultz has spoken quite
openly about his uh irritation over that
but uh
it's difficult to speculate about the
emotional
side of chancellor schultz's remarks
because in fact he is very restrained as
a communicator he comes from northern
germany and he's known for
understatement if you listen to what
president steinmeier said yesterday
after his telephone conversation with
president zielenski of ukraine it was
far more effusive and in fact zolensky
did invite the president as well as the
german government to visit so possibly
chancellor schultz's hesitation is now
simply a protocol issue because normally
it is the president who makes such
official state visits uh first
now all of schultz was quite heavily
criticized
for his reaction to the snub the
ukrainian ambassador to germany accused
charlotte of sulking how much public
backing here in germany does olaf
schwartz have for the way that he's
handling this crisis in ukraine
public is very divided particularly on
whether germany should in fact meet
ukraine's request to send heavy weapons
the
number of or the share of uh polls that
actually support that of ranges between
45 to 56
of those surveyed so essentially the
country is split and that is
particularly true of members of the
chancellor's own party the social
democrats they have a long tradition of
pacifism of believing that
good commercial relations with other
countries will ensure peace and
stability and therefore this is a
difficult move for the german government
to make and we heard chancellor schultz
on the traditional union labor union
rally on may first saying to er to his
listeners in the face of cat calls that
radical pacifism has now become obsolete
so clearly he is trying to take the
public along with him but at the moment
the country is split for fear of being
drawn into this conflict
melinda crane dw's chief political
correspondent thank you so much
and we're going to cross now to dw's
chief political editor michela kufner
who is traveling with the german defense
minister in slovakia michigan what can
you tell us about the minister's visit
yeah it's here in slovakia that german
defense minister christine lamprey made
the announcement that germany will
deliver seven howitzers bringing up the
number to 12 that will go towards
ukraine here behind me she's been
inspecting patriot defense systems
that's also another cooperation with the
netherlands with the dutch defense
minister here as well both countries
together will do the training on these
howitzers in germany
it will be ukrainian soldiers coming
here who will be trained and that
training is due to start as early as
next week with the howitzers being
delivered over the coming weeks we're
not getting a more precise timeline but
quite clearly uh germany willing to hand
over more heavy weapons always together
with its allies within the nato context
and also potentially willing to deliver
more that's what we're hearing we know
that there is a growing list in the
german chancellery of what can be done
so we expect this only to be the latest
step in potential future heavy weapons
deliveries
dws michaela kufna in slovakia thank you